[Music]
on the cell phones in the streets in the
cars the beats of a rap song reverberate
throughout Thailand Patek Kumi or in
English what my country has criticizes
Thailand's military government and the
lack of freedom in a country under a
military dictatorship that has struck a
chord especially among young Thais the
song got more than 20 million clicks on
YouTube in just a week it's sort of a
voice for teenagers for young adults who
can think that can't act we can only
talk amongst ourselves but we have no
Liberty or rights to speak out freely if
you do speak your mind it'll only be bad
for yourself and you can't change
anything anyway not daring to speak out
something the group rappers against
dictatorship wanted to change that's why
they wrote that it will mean we think
that anyone can use the phrase what my
country's got the title of the song to
speak out about whatever's on their mind
what they think is the matter with our
country we hope that people will start
being more critical when it comes to
politics speaking out against the
powerful has never been without risk in
Thailand but since the latest military
coup four years ago it's become even
more dangerous also
for rappers against dictatorship the
police at first declared they were
investigating the group for a possible
violation of the so called Computer
Crime Act it could get them five years
in prison but what the announcement got
the song was 5 million clicks in two
days the authorities have sent
down good eating now Kingman the lyrics
don't contain anything that insults
anyone personally that's why I never
thought the song would draw attention
from the authorities but when the police
started talking about it that's really
when it became so popular all of a
sudden male come hang it on Yacktman my
new rap PA good man on the outside
Thailand
looks like a peaceful country but there
are deep divisions time and again the
country has been on the brink of Civil
War for now the military government is
keeping a lid on things but below the
surface it's starting to heat up again
there haven't been elections in more
than four years they're scheduled for
February but what will they be worth if
society doesn't change people should
develop a critical mindset in their
everyday lives I think if that were the
case there would actually be less
conflict within society conflict happens
when people don't accept that others
have a different opinion I mean like if
we could get there
reach a compromise instead of fighting
with those who don't share our opinion
that would be an important step towards
a better future
Nana what man Manoj been singing he's a
man